this is currently the lowest price wagon
on the german market the duchy logan mcb
when it came out in 2006 as sasha the
original logan mcv was extremely
spacious and very cheap the boxy
romanian soon won fans among thrifty
families and tradesmen
the new version takes a step back from
its van associated past now the logan
mcv is being marketed as a regular
station wagon
and the differences are immediately
apparent
it has a much sleeker look with the
headlights now flush with the matte
black grille
and it has a lower roofline than its
predecessor with a more conventional
side profile
the rear is where the logan's new image
as a family car is in its best light
instead of the split rear doors it has a
classic trunk hatch which proudly bears
the name of the model
we think the old version was quirkier
and more individual
it's a full 13 centimeters shorter than
the old version bringing it down to 151
centimeters average for its class
instead of commercial customers it's now
more geared to normal families
and they are quite keen on the new logan
mcv
judging by advance orders dacia can
hardly keep up with demand
around 60 logan mcv's come off the
assembly line every hour at the planet
potechia romania that adds up to 350 000
per year a worrying number for other
manufacturers in europe that's because
the top of the line logan mcv can be had
in germany for under 14 000 euros
sasha says to keep fuel consumption as
low as possible dacia has helped itself
to reno's modern engines
there's the 0.9 liter three cylinder
unit also used in the renault clio it
delivers 66 kilowatts or 90 horsepower
and only consumes five liters of fuel
per 100 kilometers
dacia offers two gasoline engines for
the duchy logan mcv along with a diesel
and a natural gas option
going flat out the three cylinder
gasoline version can reach a maximum of
175 kilometers per hour accelerating
from zero to 100 requires patience 11.1
seconds although no one should be
expecting high performance from a 66
kilowatt engine
but a concept the change to the concept
of the 4.49 meter long car has
unfortunately also taken its toll on the
trunk the old model had an unrivaled 700
to 2 350 liters of luggage capacity but
now we have just a very ordinary 573 to
1518 liters
if you fold down the front passenger
seat you get a loading length of 2.74
meters
although the available space can't match
that of its predecessor the trunk is
extremely flexible folding down the rear
seats produces a more or less flat
surface
unfortunately says sasha there is no
optional third seat row in the new
generation
in its place a spare tire a jack and a
set of tools
sasha says with the new logan mcv dacha
is following its usual strategy that is
the basic version is extremely cheap at
7990 euros but is virtually naked
especially in terms of the interior you
have to pay more to get a navigation
system and air conditioning
compared to its predecessor the interior
is
a much more appealing
a comparison of the old and the new
three-part dashboard makes this clear
the arm rest is well-intentioned but
still lacks a solid feel
that said all trim levels include power
steering four airbags and esp
time for our verdict
the logan mcv has little competition on
the price front you'd usually pay 20 000
euros for a wagon of comparable size
even a mini wagon would still cost you
around ten thousand and you'd have to
make compromises in terms of space
dacia wants to direct customers needing
more room to the new logi and docker but
if the space in the logan mcv is
sufficient it offers a very good price
performance ratios
ah music to the ears of motorsports fans
after a 16-year hiatus from the top
class of the le mans endurance series
porsche will be making its long overdue
return to lmp1 next summer the car
maker's slogan is straightforward enough
mission 2014 our return
despite the lengthy layoff porsche is
still the record title holder at le mans
and is not just here for nostalgia or to
make up the numbers
porsche essentially started from scratch
explains its director of lmp1
engineering they had a tiny team toiling
away on the concept but which then grew
rapidly there's been a lot of work
involved they basically had a moving
target principle as regards the
regulations because
they would continually evolve
the new regulations present tough
challenges to both the engineers and the
drivers
timo bernhard will be on the grid
proportion next summer in the le mans
prototype 1 class or lmp1
porsche's return in 2014 will be
accompanied by new regulations which
incorporate a far greater emphasis on
efficiency that means driving as quickly
as possible while using a minimum of
fuel
new challenges that will also raise the
pulses of old hands
former racing director manfred yanke
explains the differences
the biggest difference between the old
days and now is vehicle operation
back then you had more time so you
tended to break and shift all the way
down which would take several seconds
these days it's all more intense
you break late and the gears engage just
like that
the pressure for the driver today is
having to manage everything in fast
motions
porsches have never been slow coaches of
course but this is le mans
plus there's greater pressure because of
the car maker's long absence
hans hammond co-steered porsche to its
first outright le mans victory in 1970
this is the continuity the continuity
the ambition and the reliability are all
crucial as well as being super fast you
have to keep that up for a long distance
and you want that performance over many
years i hope that in 2014 porsche will
pick up where it left off
porsche's lmp1 boss fritz ensingha and
his team are out to establish a new era
and the marriage of top performance and
efficiency is also of interest to
regular car buyers
the appeal of le mans lies in the mix of
team spirit strategy and engineering a
24-hour race is obviously really long
there's excitement surrounding the whole
enterprise
and the special appeal for the
manufacturer is demonstrating the
technology and durability
is a showcase for technology but also a
useful proving ground when it comes to
potential features for production cars
former driver jurgen bart is delighted
to see le mans once more becoming a
standard bearer of future technology
you have all the hybrid developments
with the restricted fuel volumes the
electronic assists and what have you
his only concern is for the driver
having to keep his eye on too many other
things and perhaps forgetting to focus
on the track
and this is the baby that will be on the
track next summer porsha is being rather
coy about details especially as its
rivals have a head start when it comes
to hybrid experience
we are definitely underdogs but that
doesn't mean we don't have a chance or
believe that we can't win
mission 2014 our return a return to
glory former race ace richard atwood
reckons his old team will surprise many
i
think
my money might be with
porsche
two-time the man winner chris van lenap
is likewise expecting porsche to triumph
they think i think it's great for the
brand and the company they definitely
have a chance of winning i'll bet on
that
chancellor
volkswagen has further expanded its
gasoline and diesel powertrain line for
the gulf with an economical and
environmentally friendly natural gas
version the gulf tgi the four-cylinder
engine is bivalent meaning it can also
run on gasoline the natural gas tank has
a range of 440 kilometers great fuel
economy and an agile 81 kilowatts of
power the new golf tgi blue motion is
available at a price of 23 400 euros in
germany
alfa romeo has unveiled its latest
gillette the 2014 model sports a new
chrome grille surround and a modified
fog light mount the output of the
mid-range diesel engine has also been
given a boost
the 16-valve 2-liter jtdm now generates
110 kilowatts starting price in germany
19
250 euros
what do hannibal's elephants and this
rsq3 have in common ponders matas not
just the color trekking across the alps
audi organized a special tour to test
the mountain credentials of its
high-performance compact suv from
cloggenfort austria to monaco and back
matas was desperate to ride along for at
least a short section of the expedition
let's see how the car does on those
tough alpine passes
the rs badge from the german for racing
sport adorns audi's highest performance
models
the low down on the souped up q3 five
cylinders a two and a half liter
displacement 228 kilowatts but why pick
the smallest member of the q family for
the upgrade
the porsche cayenne cemented the arrival
of performance suvs audi has now taken
the smallest suv in its range and
produced a real pace monster the rsq3
there is also an sq5 but no rsq5 that
makes the rsq3 the sportiest suv in the
audi family
suv
the swiss alps are twisty and tricky
terrain quattro four wheel drive makes
light work of those hairpin bends while
the engine is loads of fun along
straight sections this segment there's
been major growth in the compact suv
segment explains audi's thomas zimmerman
audi wanted to become the first car
maker among its rivals to launch a car
like this
the regular q3 model debuted in 2011 the
rs version's 228 kilowatts see it out
power bmw's x1 and the new gla from
mercedes
it also outstrips them on the price
front however prices for the rsq3 in
germany start at 54
600 euros
the new model shares the features of
other rs models explains the audi
project manager such as a five-cylinder
turbo familiar from the rs3 it's great
for everyday use thanks to the
functionality of the interior then there
are its off-road abilities too
but off-road talent seems less important
than the view from the high seating
position even so the rs is 25
millimeters lower than the regular q3
it wouldn't be mantas first choice for
tackling off-road territory all the
off-road parts that are normally housed
in raw plastic with a regular q3 now
have a paint finish and pick up
scratches very easily this is very much
an suv for the street
suv
with suspension on the firm side the
rsq3 does give you that sports car
feeling despite the high center of
gravity the car makes the dash to 100
kilometers an hour and 5.5 seconds top
speed is electronically limited to 250.
we took a closer look at the new model
at an altitude of over two thousand
meters
the revamped front is dominated by the
single frame radiator grille with a
honeycomb design grid the wheel wells
have flared out a little the new
addition has shiny painted trim
everywhere
a roof spoiler optimizes the downforce
when you pick up the pace
the rsq3 may not be your ideal alpine
escort but it is more fun tackling
curves than driving straight ahead
that's something the great grip on the
steering wheel and the precise steering
response ensure
audi claims an official fuel consumption
of 8.8 liters per 100 kilometers a
figure that is indeed achievable but
only if you don't fancy much fun at the
wheel
found the expedition challenging because
you're in a fast car but only as fast as
the driver in front and after eight
hours on the road it's time to relax
after the second world war germany's
economic miracle had many manifestations
the volkswagen beetle symbolized
mobility for the masses meanwhile many
small companies used the tough little
temple matador to pick up supplies and
distribute goods delivery personnel
swore by the little all-purpose vehicle
test driver christoph bauer says a
different image comes to mind when he
hears the word matador agile graceful
and glamorous with plenty of shiny
chrome trim the four-wheeled matador is
nothing like that it's a hearty honest
workhorse
this matador is the world's best
restored and most authentic it rolled
off the assembly line of hamburg's
temple plant in 1951
thereafter it shifted scrap and hay
businessman oscar videl began building
three-wheel delivery trucks in 1928.
in 1950 a more robust four-wheeled
version the matador was first produced
it has a four cylinder 25 horsepower
boxer engine built in behind the front
axle
christopher says when he hears the motor
under the seat he knows exactly what the
matador is all about he says it's a vw
boxer up until 1952 that is when the
matador began to compete with the vw
type 2 more commonly known as a vw van
that's when vw engines and the matador
never sounded as good again
bauer goes on to say that the matador is
a real looker and if he's interpreting
the looks correctly the car is a real
favorite with the ladies
and the matador wasn't only a
heartbreaker with independent wheel
suspension and front-wheel drive it was
also a trendsetter for most of today's
small
bauer trucks the vehicle as an
easy-going little truck saying that you
get plenty of sympathy points on the
street particularly from dog owners
maybe because the unkind say the tempo's
front looks like the squashed in nose of
a boxer
it looks a bit sad he says the engine
isn't what's behind the short snout but
the fuel tank so you really don't want
to get into an accident with it
bauer tells us the 25 horsepower engine
is behind the front axle and that the
little truck chugs along but when you're
distributing beer maybe time isn't
exactly of the essence
he notes that the paint is new after
painstaking restoration in california
where it's perfectly suited for use as a
surf buggy but since the truck was
designed for work it's time to get back
on the job
these things here in sofia after
while on a worldwide quest for original
parts the american restorer stumbled
across a complete load of old beer
bottles and original wooden crates from
a bavarian brewery he quickly
resurrected the matador as an authentic
beer delivery truck
the tempo can also be seen at the site
house museum at the autostart in
wolfsburg
says the car makers followed the if you
don't have it it can't break rule the
matador has no extras nothing that isn't
absolutely necessary he tells us the
vehicle was used to move goods from
point a to point b whether it was coal
or scrap and the matador worked but with
a top speed of around 65 kilometers per
hour it wasn't fast
after vw stopped supplying boxer engines
it was the end of the road for tempo as
a make a vehicle even the two-stroke
engines from elo and four-stroke motors
from heinkel and austin couldn't stop
the slide matadors stopped coming off
the line in 1955 after a five-year
production run that turned out thirteen
thousand five hundred twenty-one
vehicles
our test driver says that when you look
at the design with front wheel drive
lightweight construction and individual
suspension of all four wheels it can be
said that the hamburg company was
already meeting the expectations
consumers have for small commercial
vehicles today he says that viewed in
that way the matador was a real
milestone in automotive history and a
very pleasant one
tempo's matador is part of the german
economic miracle but not with a happy
ending nevertheless the fame and
reputation of genuine matador lives on
forever
you